♪
♪ OUT DRINKIN
WITH MY BOYS LATE NIGH
COME HOME TO
MY LADY PAST MIDNIGHT ♪
♪ SHE'S WAITING U
SHE THROWING ME SHAD
WE HAVING WORD
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAYS ♪
♪ SHE SAID I'M OUT TOO LATE
SHE PUSHED ME AWAY
THERE AIN'T NOTHING IN
THE WORLD THAT I CAN SAY ♪
♪ SO I'M SLEEPING
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT
SHE GOT ME
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ NOW I'M SLEEPIN
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT
I'M SLEEPING
ON THE COUCH ♪
♪ WORKING LAT
MAKING PAPER
HITTING DEADLINE ♪
♪ COMING HOME
I WAS STROLLIN
IN THE BEDTIME ♪
♪ I BOUGHT A SHEET SHEE
SHE ONLY KNOWS
I ACT A LO
BUT I ALREADY KNOW ♪
♪ I'M ON THE COUCH TONIGH
SHE GOT ME
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ SHE IN BE
ALL TUCKED IN TIGH
BUT I'M SLEEPING
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ I'M SLEEPIN
ON THE COUCH
MAKE DINNE
LIKE LOVERS DO ♪
♪ I BOUGHT HER WINE
AND I'M SLEEPING
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ SHE GOT M
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT
DON'T SLEEP TO
IT'S TIME ♪
♪ SLEEPING ON
THE COUCH TONIGH
SHE GOT ME ON THE COUCH ♪
♪ WAKE HER UP
WITH ROSES ON THE BE
TELL HER ALL THE SWEET
THOUGHTS IN MY HEAD ♪
♪ SHE ROLL AROUND
AND I'M SLEEPING
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ SHE GOT ME ON THE COUCH
SHE SAYS I ♪
♪ SLEEPING ON
THE COUCH TONIGH
SHE GOT ME ON THE COUCH ♪
♪ I SAY HELLO AND
♪ I'M SLEEPIN
ON THE COUCH TONIGHT
SLEEPING O
THE COUCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ SHE GOT ME ON THE
WE ALL MAK
MISTAKES IT'S TRUE
TELL ME WHAT I GOT TO DO ♪
♪ GET BACK IN
THE BEDS WITH YO
WHAT DID I EVER DO TO YOU ♪
♪ CHEATED ON ME
ALMOST EVERY DAY
I CAUGHT YOU CHEATIN
ON ME YESTERDAY ♪
♪ YOU DID
♪ YOU EVEN CHEATE
ON ME ON MY COUC
THAT'S WHY YOUR ASS IS
IN THE DOGHOUSE ♪
♪ I AIN'T MAD ABOUT YOU
WORKING LATE
BUT YOU GOT 10 CREDIT CARD
IN MY NAME ♪
♪ YOU MAX THEM OU
NOW MY CREDIT'S BA
WHY DID YOU TAKE OUT
LIFE INSURANCE ON ME ♪
♪ WE BROKE UP FIVE YEARS AG
I GOT MARRIED TO ANOTHER GUY
HE'S SICK OF YOU
CRASHING HERE ♪
♪ YOU REALLY HAVE TO STOP
COMING OVER HERE ♪
>> YOU REALLY CAN'T KEEP COMING
HERE
I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO
STAY, BUT WE GOT KIDS.
>> NO.
>> NO BUTS, IT'S GOT TO STOP,
OKAY
ALL RIGHT, WELL, SEE YOU AROUND.
♪ I'M SLEEPIN
IN MY CAR TONIGH
SLEEPING IN MY CAR ♪
>> YOU CAN'T PARK IN THE DRIVE
WAY, BUDDY, COME ON, YOU GOT TO
GO
LET'S GO
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAND THERE
AND WATCH ME LEAVE
>> NO, I DON'T HAVE TO, BUT I'M
GOING TO
♪